what's next rusty well we've got a
fascinating interview technique you may
not have heard of emma said money
reports famous inventor thomas edison
heart of him well he loved to start
every interview with something that
surprised me he started interviews with
soup drew yeah he conducted his
interviews at lunch and he ordered soups
for everybody at the table and then he'd
watch to see what you did and
specifically if you salted your soup
before or after you tasted it because if
the person salted it before tasting it
they were out edison didn't want people
who acted on assumptions he wanted
people who were thoughtful and willing
to investigate and i know as a cook well
i cook every day and when i make
something for someone and they salt it
or put hot sauce on it i'm like
how dare you do you understand i i
made this dish for you it's perfect in
my eyes at least give me the the respect
of trying it before you season it can i
get an amen yeah pilar and i i always if
i have to like salt anything pilar and i
made i feel like i'm you know going to
hell or as my daughter says he double
hockey stick cute um
i um
this story really does it for me
and i'll tell you why because the great
minds of our world time history i am
fascinated to know how did they become
who they are so any little tidbit or
morsel of information into the mind of
thomas edison
hello i mean this room could be pitch
black if he hadn't literally yeah
invented the light bulb hey thomas
thanks for great lighting thank you so
much thank you and what i loved about
this is when i was finding out about it
they teased me they said okay he made
everybody eat soup
when he initially met them why do you
think and i was like to see if they're a
slurper i don't know
i didn't i didn't know and learning that
he wanted to find out the
trajectory of one's behavior
by i don't even want to
try this before i assume
was deductive reasoning for him to
decide whether to join forces with that
person or not fascinating are you going
to try this
well i do usually try it um because i do
i work with pilar we're cooking all the
time and i think it is really rude and
embarrassing to salt your food
in front of people who made it like i
have to really be desperate for it
because i know i'm saying directly to
them sorry it wasn't seasoned perfectly
um what's weird is i have certain times
of the year
where i can't handle salt and i'm like
it's too salty and there's like not salt
in it so i don't know if that's a
hormonal thing or not but
i am sensitive about people who cook and
salting you know what i'm sensitive
about don't order me soup i want the
salad how dare you
what is the soup today can we have that
conversation first
well finally we have a pick from drew's
little yellow book yes that's right
it is
my personal curation that i work with
everyone on the show with because i
think that if i was a professional
curator i would be happy
so we refresh it every single week we're
very thoughtful about it we do all the
picks ourselves and this week i'm
excited because i did a social post
about this and it just brings me to
nostalgia city i just seen spider-man
and has anyone seen spider-man here i
hear it's so great it is so good and it
is about the power of three
and which takes me back to the best time
a
you know girl could ever have and that
was being one of
three with the charlie's angels so
flower beauty made this flower beauty x
charlie's angels palette which is now
available exclusively with our beauty
partners at cvs and you can get it on
flowerbeauty.com
and it looks like a dvd and there's all
these treats with it and uh the colors
are like angel's eyes starfish which is
what tom green called me in the movie i
liked it so much i married him
um speaking of there's the chad dylan
good morning angels independent women
hey because i will never forget being in
the trailer and we we heard the demo
from destiny's child come in i just
heard that song the other day and i was
like drew
that's you
you get a shower and that's like does
that get this hello with my girl drew
cameron d and destiny charlie's angels
come on and they were three women yes
they were i mean being in you know your
early 20s and trying to produce the
charlie's angels movie and hear
destiny's child songs coming in it was
just
it was the best time that's so amazing
in the world was it it really was it was
you know we spent five years making two
of those movies they each took two years
to make we trained we toured the world
we became best friends
you know it was us three girls and there
is something about that trinity that
trio that
triangle that's unshakable and um
yeah so this feels very meaningful for
me to be a part of and put out in the
world right now so if you want to get in
touch with your inner little superhero
go to cvs or the flower beauty website
and get your flower beauty x charlie's
angels palette
[Music]
you